This podcast is brought to you by bespoke Post's box of awesome.
Everything you can imagine doing in the vicinity of our son, for example,
like having various objects in orbit around it, essentially,
uh, you know, for billions of years, you can do that with a black hole as well,
just because the black hole is there.
It doesn't mean that it's some big vacuum cleaner. That sucks things in.
Pete. I know, you know, a little bit about black holes.
I do because on what if every eight third video,
every third video? Yeah, we do a lot of black hole videos here,
but that speaks to.
The fact that tons of people are fascinated with black holes.
Yes,
it's a fascinating subject because most people know nothing about them other
than their one black than they're a black hole, that sucks stuff into them.
And as we'll find out in today's show,
there's going to be some myths and misconceptions about black holes that will be
answered because a lot of the things we think we do know are starting to change,
but that's why we have guests like physics professors on the show to be able to
help us sort out things like what if our solar system orbited a black hole
today, we're going to be joined by USC professor of physics, Clifford Johnson,
but first some good news for the,
what if discussed community.
Well that's right. Uh, this fall, as you get back into the swing of things,
bespoke post has a brand new seasonal box of awesome collection for guys
guaranteed to upgrade your life. Uh,
this month I got the aged box and that's a kit that lets me barrel age,
my spirits at home. And when I say spirits, I mean liquors,
which lifts your spirits. Sometimes there it does.
I'm pretty excited about an aging, some gin right now,
and your age it for 10 days, and today is day 10. So I'll let you know.
Oh my box of awesome. A couple of things.
I was torn between the gadget thing that, you know, I live in a condo.
So anything that can sort of check the boxes on a million different tool
applications is great, but I ultimately, the travel bag is super cool.
Cause I'm somebody who likes to,
if I'm going away for like 10 days or a hundred days,
I want to carry on in that sense.
That one, but I haven't been traveling anywhere lately.
Thanks to you all so true. Yeah.
Whether it's geared to upgrade your autumn craft beers or cozy threads for when
the temperature dips,
bespoke posts only sends guys the best stuff every month,
no matter what you're into box of. Awesome.
Has you covered from style and grooming goods to barware cooking tools and
outdoor gear box of awesome has collections for every part of your life to get
started, take the quiz@boxofawesome.com.
Your answers will help them pick the right box of awesome for you.
They release new boxes every month across a ton of different categories.
Like I said, it's free to sign up and you can skip a month or cancel any time.
So no, a real commitment. Each box costs only 45 bucks,
but has over 70 bucks worth of gear inside.
I've got a bunch of extra money these days from not spending cash on gas or
transit. So 45 bucks seems quite reasonable,
especially when you get double the value. Yeah. Yeah.
You get 20% off your first monthly box when you sign
up@boxofawesome.com and enter the code.
What if at checkout that's box of awesome.com code?
What if all one word for 20% off your first box?
So let's get started. And again, like we talked about off the top black holes,
you and I, a superficial knowledge at best again, that's why,
uh, we like to have experts on the show to help us understand in this case,
what if our solar system orbited a black hole? I don't really know the answer.
I'm pretty sure you don't know the answer. So we're joined by again,
professor of physics from the university of Southern California,
Clifford Johnson.
Hi, great to be here.
Uh, professor, thanks for joining us. Uh,
it sounds like a simple question to start, but it, we might as well go there.
What is a black hole?
Well,
that is something that does come into various of these fields
in a way,
because we think about the nature of space and time and
a black hole is fundamentally something very,
very fundamentally different about space and time that we had thought that that
had been thought of until the last, um, uh, century, uh,
of, of, of work in great detail. And what it is we,
we understand in general is simply a region of
space where for whatever reason,
the gravitational pull is so strong that not even light
can escape from it in the sense that, you know,
if we wanted to get off this body here earth, uh, we, we, we send,
we send rockets away, uh,
into space and we do that by getting up to a certain speed,
a certain escape velocity, which allows you to excrete escape,
the gravitational pull and, uh,
for reasons that we, we could go into, but, but let's not for now, uh,
there's a, there's a fastest possible speed that you can do in this universe.
It's the speed of light. So if you had a body that was so, uh,
gravitationally strong that the escape speed was faster than the speed of light,
then nothing would be able to escape from it. And that's what a black hole.
There's, there's various, uh, levels of black hole. As I understand it,
it's kind of like the Wendy's drive through there's your regular black hole and
there's their super massive black hole.
Medium, a triple a double what's the difference.
Between a regular and a supermassive black hole?
Well, one of the amazing things about black holes is that they are, uh,
by some definitions, very, very complicated. And by other definitions,
they are the simplest objects in the universe that we've ever
encountered in, in, in physics. Uh, and so in some ways,
the only difference between those different kinds of black holes that you talk
about is how big they are.
And so you have black holes that are say,
have roughly a few times the mass of our sun because they come
from stars that have, in some sense died,
they've gone to a new phase of existence where they're no longer glowing like
stars and they collapse and they form this compact object.
And so they have a mass that is essentially related to the stuff that
collapsed. Um, but then you have regions of space, uh,
for example, at the core of most galaxies,
where there are black holes that are huge hundreds
of millions of times, the mass of a typical star.
And in some sense,
they're very closely related to those smaller kinds of black holes.
And there are also intermediate mass black holes,
and some of us speculate that they may also be microscopic black holes, uh,
as a possibility of nature as well.
All shapes and sizes, yes. A kid's meal. Um, one of the,
I guess more recently it's being called a misconception or a myth about black
holes. I know for the most part in the Saifai world, you know,
it was always portrayed that you get sucked into a black hole. Basically,
if you were, you know, in too close proximity to a black hole, that was it.
You couldn't, you couldn't help but get sucked in. That's not exactly true,
is it.
Exactly right? Again, you should think of a black hole as,
uh, in many of its properties.
It's very similar to any big blob of matter that you can have,
uh, if you're, if you're far away enough, uh, from it.
And so everything you can imagine doing in the vicinity of our son, for example,
like having various objects in orbit around it, essentially,
uh, you know, for billions of years, you can do that with a black hole as well,
just because the black hole is there.
It doesn't mean that at some big vacuum cleaner that, um,
that sucks things in, uh, which is, you know, often portrayed that way.
It makes it feel like some kind of, uh, some kind of, uh, intentional, uh,
behemoth. Um, no,
th they're just gravitating objects like anything else. And so you can,
you can, you can, uh, you can be near a black hole for an arbitrarily long time.
The issue then is what happens if you get to
that point of closest approach whereby you then didn't
have enough, uh, engine power to, uh, to escape,
or even if you had all the engine power in the world,
you couldn't get faster than the speed of light to get away.
And that's called crossing the event horizon,
and there is point of closest approach, which you then wouldn't be able to, uh,
at least classically, uh, and I could explain what that means, um, uh, escape.
Uh, but if you're, if you're,
if you're not within the event horizon in principle, you can, you can,
you can approach and, and move away and it doesn't suck you in.
Well, I guess the big, what if for today is, uh, what if, uh, uh,
our solar system orbited a black hole? Is it possible? I think,
I think from what you're saying,
it is possible for a planet or a solar system to orbit a black hole,
but is it also possible for them to orbit a black hole and sustain life?
I would say my guess is probably yes. Uh,
and I can imagine a number of different scenarios, uh, where that could,
where that could come about. So for example, uh,
well, let,
let's first dispense with the issue of whether we think there may be other
forms of life on other planets. Let's say that's not, um, not, you know,
beyond the, uh, the, the realm of possibility.
And you've probably discussed that in other shows. So let's say that there are,
uh, other stars for which there are other, uh,
other maybe earth Lake, or maybe not enough light, but they have a life. Now,
it might be that that star, uh,
may have been part of a binary system. For example,
whether you have a double star, two stars orbiting each other,
and then there are planets orbiting that system.
You can imagine that sort of thing. And maybe one of those, uh,
became a black hole. Um, it might've been that it, it,
uh,
it happened with some sort of cataclysmic explosion as often happens called a
supernova explosion and type two supernova explosion that may well have
obliterated all the life, uh, nearby.
But let's say let's let let's say it didn't um, then you could,
you could, that could actually be a rather unusual from our perspective, but a,
a home for, uh,
for that form of life or another possibility
is that you have some star faring species that intentionally
seeks out a black hole and decides to, um, settle around it,
that the build an object, which orbits it, or they, they,
they occupy some planetary matter that is
old between that, that black hole. And that becomes their star system.
It turns out you can actually mine black holes for energy in a certain kind of
way.
And they would be among the most efficient sources of energy.
If you could do the kind of engineering you would need to, to exploit it.
So maybe there are super advanced civilizations that are living around black
holes. Sorry.
I going to say that literally sounds that Peter's wearing a t-shirt that says
that's a story for another, what if mining.
Block holes for energy is exactly a story for another,
what if that is so cool and not something I think we've,
we've even heard about here, but we will explore it. Um,
lots of mysteries around black holes and a lot of MIS conceptions about black
holes. So thank you, professor Johnson for helping us clear some of those up,
uh, we're gonna, we're gonna have a longer conversation with prevents, uh,
professor Johnson on the other side, before we do,
where's the best place for people to follow your work?
Oh, gosh. Um, well, uh,
I would say they could probably, uh,
either find me through my blog all through Twitter or Facebook or
Instagram. Um, it's probably best just to Google me. I,
my handle on those things is usually something called ASIN, Tosha,
but telling you to spell that, uh,
it's easy if you just Google my name and physics and you'll find me,
and a nice compact way is to,
is to look at a graphic nonfiction book I wrote and drew a couple of years ago
called the dialogues where actually I talk about some of these issues.
Great stuff, professor Johnson, uh, not surprising.
Obviously we always get to learn cool stuff here on what if discuss what we're
here for. Um, if you would ask me prior,
do black hole suck things in like a vacuum cleaner as he so eloquently put it,
I would have said, yes, this is what we've learned.
That's what we've seen in movies and TV 10 episodes of star Trek based on it.
But as it turns out that mass,
that incredible mass actually just creates gravity. Some people will say tomato,
tomato, but I think it's a good clarification. What did you learn?
I learned that you can, I was really impressed that you could mine a black hole.
That's super, I mean,
I haven't learned more but enough about that because I want to ask him that sort
of stuff on the other side. So, uh,
we will continue our discussion with professor Johnson on the extended audio
version of the podcast. So, uh, if you would like to join us for more,
just click on the link below. If you're already listening on the audio podcast,
there's nothing for you to click, just stay with us.
We'll be back with more professor Johnson, otherwise,
thanks everyone for joining us on. What if discussed.